bonsoir Le 7 8 lectue sur tvfils 78 le
tour de l'actualité locale il est 18h si
vous nous rejoignez en direct et voici
donc les principaux titres si plaisir
est vilpreux travaille déjà ensemble
dans le cadre de la future
intercommunalité les rapports sont
toujours tendus avec leur autre
partenaire les clés sous bois nouvelle
réunion ce matin en mairie de plaisir
pour présenter les statues qui seront
votés ce jeudi soir dans les conseils
municipaux l'occasion pour les deux élus
de pousser un coup de colère contre
certains propos tenus par Véronique côté
Millard la mère donc des
Clayes-sous-Bois un rapport difficile
également entre la FCPE et la ville de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux la fédération de
parents d'élèves reprochent à l'équipe
municipale de ne pas mener correctement
les débats autour des rythmes scolaires
et puis l'association agissait contre la
violence morale à mort pas une nouvelle
fois dans le rouge les subventions
manquent sa présidente s'en remet à la
solidarité il manque 10.000 euros pour
finaliser le budget et on débute donc
avec cette information hier devait se
tenir le conseil d'administration de
l'Université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
Yvelines un conseil important puisque
figurette à l'ordre du jour le vote du
budget 2014 la réunion a finalement été
reportée elle l'intersey syndicale qui
manifestait devant la Faculté des
Sciences hier mercredi à Montigny vous
le voyez à empêcher la tenue de ce
conseil à interpeller le président de
l'université Jean-Luc Bessières pour lui
demander d'assumer un budget en déficit
sans restriction budgétaire et c'est par
un communiqué en fin de journée que la
présidence de l'université s'est
exprimée je vous lis cet extrait du
communiqué afin d'accompagner les
efforts importants de la communauté
universitaire un soutien accru de l'État
en matière de dotation et d'emploi et
d'urgence ce sont les propos du
président de l'université faute de cela
l'hypothèse d'une fermeture en février
après et les examens du début d'année
elle n'est pas à exclure le président
qui évoque donc ce soir la possibilité
de voir fermer cette université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
rappelons qu'elle affiche un déficit de
5 millions d'euros un nouvel un nouveau
pardon conseil d'administration doit se
tenir en janvier
le premier janvier prochain les villes
devront tout intégrer une
intercommunalité dans certains cas cela
coince et même beaucoup et c'est le cas
pour l'intercommunalité entre
plaisirville-preux et Les
Clayes-sous-Bois dans cette dernière
commune la mer Véronique cottémia
merudéhy n'a participé à aucune réunion
les deux autres élus sont agacés
Catherine zulato et le dimone pour les
précisions
dans mon coin c'est pas possible je suis
désolé c'est pas un exemple à donner la
mère de plaisir est en colère en colère
contre Véronique côté milliard son
homologue des Clayes-sous-Bois qui ne
veut pas intégrer la communauté de
communes que ces villes doivent
constituer avec Villepreux un mariage à
trois qui débute bien mal et si jusqu'à
présent le ton était amical un article
publié dans le journal municipal des
Clayes-sous-Bois jeté de l'huile sur le
feu on a constaté des propos qu'on ne
peut pas accepter des propos venant des
Clayes-sous-Bois qui sont des propos de
critiques
portés sur la ville de plaisir et sur
Villepreux également des propos
évoquants des sommes qui seraient qui
encombraient aux chrétiens si
effectivement les clés rentraient dans
cette intercommunalité des chiffres de 1
million d'euros c'est complètement
erroné et puis je n'accepte pas non plus
qu'on puisse dire que plaisir est une
ville surendettée
que la ville de plaisir était endettée
dans le journal ou vraiment il faudrait
me montrer la ligne
tenir par contre effectivement que le
que nous pourrions éventuellement perdre
une partie des recettes de one nation
et effectivement quelque chose qu'on a
écrit puisque c'est une c'est une
réalité ça pourrait être une ça pourrait
devenir une réalité j'aimerais qu'on
garde beaucoup d'élégance dans ce dans
cette dans cette création
d'intercommunalité et de compréhension
et puis surtout d'ambition politique et
surtout savoir que quand on était élu on
a des responsabilités on doit appliquer
la loi car l'intercommunalité entre ces
trois villes est actée depuis le 23
septembre avec ou sans la participation
des plaies elle continue à se nouer son
nom a été dévoilé ce mercredi communauté
de communes de l'Ouest parisien et un
projet de statut présenté avec deux
compétences d'études liées au
développement économique et au transport
nous avons convié la ville des clés à
chaque réunion à chaque fois il y a eu
un transfert d'informations qui a été
fait les comptes rendus fourni à la
ville des Clayes-sous-Bois nous n'avons
jamais eu le moindre retour et on a même
senti un blocage où il y avait une
volonté de ne pas nous transmettre la
moindre information plaisir et villes
retiendront leurs conseils mun pas le
jeudi pour enterrer les statues de cette
nouvelle intercommunalité une première
réunion des nouveaux élus communautaires
est prévu courant janvier reste à savoir
si la ville des Clayes-sous-Bois y
participera
sur les statues aucune réunion on a été
commis aucune réunion
par sandwich
une affaire donc encore à suivre à la
rentrée scolaire 2014 l'ensemble des
vilyvelinoises devront appliquer la
réforme des rythmes scolaires en pleine
concertation à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
elle afcpe considère que les conditions
de la représentation des parents ne sont
pas aujourd'hui réunis au sein des
comités de travail état des lieux de
cette situation avec Anthony Reich et
Olivier Maniscalco
vendredi dernier le comité technique
travaillant sur la réforme des rythmes
scolaires à Montigny-le-Bretonneux vote
un temps périscolaire d'une heure 30
répartie sur de jours deux fois par
semaine les enfants finiront à 15h un
vote réalisé sans live CPE qui n'a pas
siégé faute de suppléant disponible on
veut surtout pas qu'on couper le contact
avec avec ce qui se passe en comité donc
on
continue à recevoir les emails et on
réagit aux emails mais on aurait
vraiment besoin que les réunions se
fassent à partir de 17h et c'est ce qui
se fait dans d'autres communes le maire
inimontin doit encore entériner la
décision et la transmettre au directeur
académique en vue de l'application de la
réforme de comité travail depuis janvier
dernier membre du comité technique la
FCPE demande intégrer celui dit de
pilotage là où semblait être menée la
réflexion et la prise de décision selon
la fédération de parents d'élèves qui
réclame des horaires de réunion adaptés
à 17h et n'ont pas en pleine journée
tout comme les autres fédérations il y a
aussi un suppléant ils ont siégé tout le
temps quand même depuis le début enfin
j'ai repris
j'ai repris toutes les tous les comptes
rendus etc et tout le monde a été
présent voilà donc c'est nous faire un
petit peu un mauvais procédé d'intention
mais bon à la rentrée 2014 les enfants
inondins devraient travailler le
mercredi matin avec des matinées plus
longues pour profiter de leur capacité
de concentration
la réforme des rythmes qui doit donc
s'appliquer dès le mois de septembre
2014 sauf bouleversement à l'issue des
élections municipales et dans votre
commune comment cela va s'organiser
quels sont les changements qui vous
attendent la consultation se
passe-t-elle tout simplement bien
quelques réponses avec ce micro-trottoir
je fais partie des parents d'élèves donc
moi oui forcément et on essaye de tout
faire pour que les parents soient au
courant mais effectivement c'est assez
compliqué pour le moment j'en sais pas
plus que ça donc maintenant on verra
l'année prochaine comment ça se
déroulera oui enfin il faut aller
chercher l'information mais la formation
est là il suffit de donc mais là on a de
toute façon comme ça va passer au
conseil
à la mairie en fonction des trucs de
l'Académie et à la réponse je sais qu'il
y a une proposition qui est faite par la
mairie et on verra si l'inspection de
l'Académie va valider ça ou pas je sais
pas exactement comment ça va passer ici
à Montigny ben vu qu'avec toi elle est
là des activités le mercredi je sais pas
comment ça va passer si c'est ça le
samedi ou le journée après l'école
donc je voudrais plus savoir aller pour
l'instant on n'est pas du tout informé
on nous a rien dit on nous a rien donné
rien
et comment ça va se passer alors pour
vous je sais pas on attend il y a eu un
début d'explication
après on va voir ce sont on a encore un
an pour voir ça et voilà
l'invité du 7 8 l'actu ce soir c'est
Chantal Paoli taxi bonsoir et bienvenue
sur ce plateau présidente de
l'association agic contre la violence
morale intrafamiliale et le stocking
basé à Maurepas vous êtes venus ce soir
malheureusement ce n'est pas la première
fois nous parler des difficultés
financières de l'Association pour la
deuxième année votre association qui est
confronté à une situation d'urgence
financière quel point on peut faire
aujourd'hui combien vous manque-t-il et
puis pourquoi alors il nous manque
environ 10000 euros pourquoi passer
toujours le problème de la baisse des
subventions et du manque d'entrée on n'a
pas eu le temps de de finaliser nos
projets d'autonomisation financière et
donc on dépend encore de la générosité
des gens c'est le budget aujourd'hui
comment ça fonctionne quels sont les
aides que deux salariés
un budget qui tourne autour de entre 70
000 et 90 000 euros avec des emplois
tremplins donc ça c'est une grossesse
mais en Platon plein qui arrive enfin de
en fin de vie donc là ça devient
beaucoup plus difficile parce qu'un
salaire chargé c'est pas du tout le même
coup
avec des subventions du Conseil Général
du Conseil régional des communes
de la CAF de
du sdfe donc de l'État et du de
différents
organismes malheureusement c'est
subventions ne sommes pas les seuls à
subir cette baisse drastique des
subventions mais c'est subventions
diminue la participation et on se
retrouve chaque année confronté à la
même difficulté à peu près au même
période c'est c'est un tournant
un tournant sur l'année suivante à à
faire qui qui est toujours difficile
2012 vous aviez aussi ce qu'on appelle
cela avait plutôt bien fonctionné
puisque vous aviez fait appel à la
générosité des gens et ça fait
fonctionner ça avait permis de maintenir
les activités combien vous avez réussi
énormément de dons parce que à l'époque
nous n'étions pas reconnus d'intérêt
général donc lorsque l'appel à a été
lancé les gens ne savaient pas qu'ils
allaient pouvoir déduire
parce que maintenant nous sommes
reconnus d'intérêt général et donc les
dons sont déductibles des impôts à 66%
je crois donc pour un don de de 60 euros
ça revient à donner 20 euros quoi
aujourd'hui je le rappelle 10000 euros
toute façon les coordonnées s'affichent
à l'écran n'hésitez pas à vous
renseigner si vous souhaitez aider cette
association on va revenir sur le travail
que vous menez bien évidemment pour bien
comprendre son importance vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure vous souhaitez avoir
plus d'autonomie en pérennisant par
exemple pour pour pérenniser les revenus
en mettant en place des formations enfin
comment tout cela fonctionne comment
vous allez réussir à être un peu plus
autonome alors il y a effectivement le
développement des formations
alors les formations
comment dire avec deux cibles c'est pas
très joli les cibles mais enfin bon la
formation des professionnels qui
commencent qui qui est balbutiante pour
l'instant et la formation alors plus
façon développement personnel pour les
personnes en situation de fragilité
la formation s'appelle faire face aux
personnalités difficiles voilà et donc
on est en train de véritablement
développer
cet aspect là de travail de
l'association on y croit beaucoup
il faut simplement que que le message
passe et que la communication se fasse à
ce sujet là ça permettrait de faire
rentrer des fonds pour l'association
tout à fait ça nous permet très enfin de
de pas d'autonomiser complètement mais
disons de pouvoir fonctionner parce que
on a sorti un livre en mars 2013
morale au quotidien et depuis la sortie
de ce livre il est vrai que les demandes
ont augmenté très sensiblement même plus
que sensiblement le problème c'est
pouvoir assurer la survie de
l'association ça veut dire travailler à
l'aide à autrui avec une épée de
Damoclès au-dessus de la tête ce qui est
vraiment pas très confortable
aujourd'hui vous devez refuser l'aide à
certaines personnes qui viennent vous
voir ont refus jamais
mais c'est vrai que du fait de demander
une participation financière ça peut
bloquer certaines personnes même si on
fait énormément de facilité c'est vrai
que du coup on ne peut pas être de
service public agissez interview près
des victimes de violences morales contre
le harcèlement vous l'avez dit
malheureusement vous ne manquez pas de
travail c'est même s'il explique en
partie ces difficultés financières
victimes de votre succès malheureusement
on va faire un point plus plus précise
sur les activités d'agissait après ce
court spot publicitaire réalisé pour
lutter contre la violence
morale
cette femme c'est un vrai boudin rien ne
lui va
il fait tout pour se faire marier
c'est une vraie traînée
cette femme a des copines mais ils sont
aussi connu
cette femme c'est la mienne
ne laissez aucune violence s'installer
réagissez appelez le 39 19
bien sûr il y a le travail des
associations nous parlons de
l'association agissée ce soir et juste
une petite parenthèse parce que là on a
regardé un cours spot qui a été réalisé
notamment par le gouvernement pour pour
lutter contre les violences ils sont
très rares ces spots c'est assez
surprenant sur la violence morale
les spots traitent beaucoup plus
effectivement de l'agrose physique
très peu malheureusement
fabuleuse et extrêmement pertinente qui
s'appelle Fred et Marie qu'il faut pas
hésiter à regarder parce que
effectivement je pense que quand on la
regarde on comprend tout alors que le
spot que nous que vous avez diffusé et
peut-être un peu moins représentatif en
tout cas les victimes de l'association
ne se sont pas complètement reconnus
dans cette présentation on parle ce soir
avec la présidente d'ajicé contre les
violences morales et le stocking vous le
disiez tout à l'heure juste avant qu'on
regarde ce spot vous avez de plus en
plus de travail cela s'explique comment
c'est le succès la notoriété de votre
association qui explique que les gens
viennent vous voir ou alors
véritablement aujourd'hui les violences
morales sont en hausse normalement dans
la société non qu'elle soit en haut dans
la société je ne crois pas simplement
c'est vrai que depuis la loi du 9
juillet 2010 il y a quand même deux
délits le délit de violence
psychologique le délit de harcèlement et
ça a libéré la parole ça a libéré la
parole et du coup c'est vrai que les
victimes osent beaucoup plus porter
plainte ou entreprendre des démarches en
tout cas pour essayer de faire
reconnaître leurs victimisation et quand
c'est pas faire reconnaître leur
victimisation par l'intermédiaire de la
justice c'est au moins être reconnu en
tant que victime et pouvoir faire une
démarche de reconstruction et nous ce
qu'on développe vraiment de plus en plus
c'est la démarche de reconstruction
est-ce que les structures comme les
vôtres sont nombreuses
comme la nôtre au niveau de la violence
morale non
il existe beaucoup d'associations de
luttes contre les violences conjugales
physiques qui accueille des femmes
victimes de violences psychologiques
aussi mais les retours que nous avons
c'est que les victimes de violences
psychologiques ne se reconnaissent pas
complètement dans dans le suivi qui est
proposé par ces associations là alors
que nous on a suivi très spécifique et
puis on a une particularité c'est
d'accueillir des hommes et des femmes et
donc de proposer des ateliers et des
groupes de parole mixtes qui sont
extrêmement riches de cette justement
mixité combien de personnes vous suivez
aujourd'hui
personnellement moi j'en suis un peu
plus de 50
alors pas au jour le jour mais
pratiquement quand même
de l'association
il doit y avoir 200 membres à peu près
mais
qui ne demande pas tous le même suivi
c'est vraiment il y a des personnes qui
n'ont besoin que d'un suivi extrêmement
ponctuel alors que d'autres ont besoin
d'un suivi beaucoup plus complet juste
pour conclure si jamais votre
association devait fermer toutes ces
personnes se retrouveraient sans
solution oui
le message est clair merci d'être venu
Chantal polycle sur ce plateau pour
parler du travail de votre association
nous poursuivons cette édition du 7 8
l'actu avec Jean-Marc Sauvé le
vice-président du Conseil d'État qui
était en visite ce lundi à la cour
administrative d'appel de Versailles
c'est la dernière année des 8 cours
d'appel que compte le territoire
national elle a été créée en 2004 et 10
ans elle a été confrontée à une
augmentation considérable des requêtes
passant de 2000 à ses débuts à plus de
4000 aujourd'hui elle compte dans son
ressort 5 départements dont celui des
Yvelines Jean-Marc Sauvé à visiter les
locaux il a rencontré les juges les
greffiers ou encore les magistrats
chaque mois ils visitent une ou deux
juridiction administrative elles sont au
nombre de 52 en métropole et outre-mer
d'administre bien un ordre de
juridiction que si on se rend sur place
pour rencontrer les acteurs et par
exemple aujourd'hui à Versailles bien on
a d'abord une réunion comme on le fait
toujours avec le président et les
présidents de chambre de la Cour d'appel
ainsi que le greffier en chef pour faire
le point sur la situation de la
juridiction ce que sont des questions
des problèmes des projets culture depuis
20 ans maintenant Yves live participe au
développement des musiques actuelles
durant le département la sélection
d'artistes organisés par le Centre de
ressources yvelinois par la musique le
CRI a accompagné des dizaines de groupes
pour célébrer cet anniversaire c'est 20
ans certains groupes se sont reformés
pour l'occasion il y a Debussy et
Jonathan Willmann
pas moins de 132 groupes et 660
musiciens ont été accompagnés dans le
développement de leur carrière
d'artistes et ce grâce au dispositiflive
créé par le Centre de ressources civiles
pour la musique plus communément appelé
le cri
ivelive fait cette année ses 20 ans bien
entendu en musique c'est au café de la
plage à Maurepas que se clôture 4 jours
de célébration un concert ou le public a
pu assister au reformations exceptionnel
de certains groupes
dans plusieurs habitants toutes les
soirées c'était vraiment superbe
pour l'occasion pour certains jusqu'à 15
ou 20 ans après et ça fait comme je
disais tout à l'heure beaucoup
d'émotions beaucoup de travail pour eux
finalement et voilà quoi ça fait
beaucoup de souvenirs qui rejaillissent
la goût
de la musique à l'époque avec ce groupe
là et que des gens du coin reviennent
voir le groupe ils n'ont pas oublié
l'ambiance qu'il avait quoi notre
éclairagiste qui était là Belek donc big
dédicace avec qui voilà qui était là ce
soir aussi avec nous on avait déjà fait
une reformation pour il y a il y a 2 ans
déjà pour turbulance qui fait partie du
réseau du cri d'ailleurs on avait sur le
plaisir de se revoir encore une fois de
toute façon de toute façon on était des
potes donc ça a été facile parce que
quand on s'est appelé pour se dire on
rejoint ensemble forcément de rejouer
avec des potes on a vécu vraiment des
moments avec ce gros plat donc ça a été
facile après plus difficile parce qu'il
y en a qui habite à Toulouse à Laval à
Brest ça c'était plus difficile pour au
niveau de la distance des uns et des
autres quoi l'occasion de se reformer on
sera là effectivement je pense qu'il y a
ce plaisir qui reste qui reste là tout
le temps c'était génial
iste mais même enthousiasme et puis nous
on les suit toujours autant donc c'est
énorme vraiment c'était bah vous voyez
là un peu chaud on a dansé on a chanté
pareil il y a 10 ans mais c'est toujours
pareil
l'Alsace a Rambouillet changement de
décor c'est jusqu'au 5 janvier dans le
cadre d'un festival de Noël et entre
deux dégustations de spécialités et de
vin chaud la possibilité de pratiquer le
patin à glace Jonathan villeman non pas
manquer l'occasion
sur cette patinoire installée à
Rambouillet Nolan accompagnée de sa
maman fait ses tout premier pas sur la
glace
la partie pour le petit où ils sont un
peu protégés
Sacha lui a préféré laisser tomber les
patins après plusieurs chutes il s'est
plutôt résigné à regarder les copains je
suis tombé une quinzaine de fois mais
bon c'est marrant mais il y a un moment
où il faut arrêter parce que ça ça fait
mal mais c'était marrant
avec une vingtaine de bénévoles Jacques
fait fonctionner cette patinoire depuis
maintenant 6 ans à l'occasion des fêtes
bon alors Émilie qu'est-ce que tu en as
pensé
c'est sympa je suis pas très stable mais
en travaillant on peut y arriver bon en
tout cas si comme nous vous voulez venir
ici la patinoire de Rambouillet c'est
tous les jours jusqu'à 5 janvier jusqu'à
19h on s'y remet Émilie c'est parti
voilà avec la participation de notre
stagiaire de 3e jusqu'au 4 janvier
l'office de tourisme de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous invite à
plonger dans la magie des contes de Noël
on reste dans cette ambiance féérique
avec un moment d'évasion en famille
Aurélia Debussy et l'audimoine
Michka Ernest Célestine et bien d'autres
amis ce sont donné rendez-vous jusqu'au
4 janvier à l'office de tourisme de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour présenter
leur compte de Noël les plus belles
pages de ces albums ornent les murs
mettant ainsi en scène l'imagination des
célèbres auteurs et illustrateurs de
contes pour enfants un moment d'évasion
en famille dans une ambiance cocooning
et magique
elle a été construit autour des contes
traditionnelles donc on a
essentiellement utilisé les
illustrations l'idée était vraiment de
recouvrir l'ensemble des murs afin de
créer justement cette atmosphère
féérique vous avez la possibilité de
lire de nombreux comptes qui sont ici à
disposition qu'on a été achetés pour
l'occasion et puis après on se balade on
s'imprègne un petit peu du décor mais il
y a pas forcément l'itinéraire prédéfini
atelier créatif jeux de piste et compte
merveilleux sont à découvrir en entrée
libre jusqu'au 4 janvier
avant de terminer ce journal sachez que
le Conseil général des Yvelines a remis
aux 80 communes lauréate les trophées
yvelinois et les prix du concours des
villes et villages fleuris de
distinction qui récompense leurs efforts
d'embellissement parmi les vainqueurs
cette année Montigny-le-Bretonneux avec
le trophée de la mairie fleurie le
trophée de l'équipement public également
ou encore la ville de Coignières avec
son trophée de l'équipement public
manilhéamo et de son côté première
commune elle dés Yvelines de 6000 à
15000 habitants au concours des villes
et villages fleuris et puis je vous
rappelle cet autre information du début
de ce journal information de cette fin
de journée suite au report du conseil
d'administration de l'Université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin hier en raison
d'une manifestation de professeurs
d'élèves et de personnels elle la
présidente a annoncé dans un communiqué
que l'aide de l'État pour faire face aux
déficit de plus de 5 millions d'euros
étaient plus que nécessaire l'option
d'une fermeture de l'Université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines en
février et maintenant avancer toutes les
réactions à suivre dans notre prochaine
édition du 7 8 lecture rendez-vous donc
demain dès 18h en direct pour en savoir
plus et puis régulièrement sur notre
site Internet pour suivre les reportages
minute après minute le journal revient
demain ce soir vous avez rendez-vous
avec Aurélia Debussy pour kiosque le
magazine culturel de la rédaction